build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people this is
beauty building
Kevin Kulik made this one-of-a-kind duck
hunt pinball machine it's an
electromechanical PC hybrid redo of a
1962 Williams valent machine that took
about a year to complete
it features manual ball loading original
sounds and display
[Music]
Santa Cruz skateboards made these Marge
and Maggie Simpson skate decks have come
together as a package Marge is thirty
seven point seven inches long and maggie
is twenty point five inches long and
they're both ten point three inches wide
and of course they have the ability to
be mounted with hardware and used like a
regular skate deck the monkey's paw in
Toronto features the Biblio mat book
vending machine that dispenses range of
books for $2 a piece imagined it built
by owner Stephen Fowler and his friend
Craig small Fowler imagined a box with
an actual person inside dispensing
random books and small took it to a
different level by building an actual
mechanical vending machine
Fowler sees it as a new spin on the
dollar cart that is classically in front
of old bookstores walk Russian artists
vet Lana Cola Silva is a mother of four
that paints fairy tales on the palm of
her hand she was inspired by the story
she read her children but didn't have
time to focus on complex oil paintings
so she decided to use the most
convenient canvas around her left hand
inspired by the dapper criminal mugshots
from the 1920s artist Jason mark
reimagines Batman villains and a vintage
mugshot series called the usual suspects
that includes Joker twoface and mr.
freeze and now for some nostalgic
Nickelodeon art celebrating the 90s
[Music]
our space graphic designer nacho or
machiya uses strange juxtapositions with
the silhouettes of pedestrians to frame
photo montages of contradicting images
leaving the meaning behind the image up
to the viewer playing Nick co-chairs of
wrapping weathermen over a KMTV CBS 11
as the morning meteorologist I tell you
a storms coming I'm not lying
predict so well you'd swear I'm a Mayan
ladies love a weatherman even on a
cloudy day guess that makes us fifty
shades of gray polvo invented the vo 96
acoustic synthesizer that creates new
sounds on the acoustic guitar through
harmonic control of string vibration
it's been tested and is ready to be
produced with the help of his
Kickstarter page
youtube-channel smooth mcgroove does
some amazing one-man acapella video
game-themed news here's his latest video
covering corridors of time from Chrono
Trigger
[Music]
[Music]
finally this is the official video for
mermaids revenge from turbo Geist
directed by Michael McCool
[Music]
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo wo
[Music]
[Music]
click here to listen to a brand new
installment of bidipi radio music
created and submitted by you guys also
check out your bidipi an entire video
dedicated to your creations and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]